pour le césar de la meilleure adaptation
maintenant costa gavras pour adeline de
blum romane polanski pour je suis accusé
j'accuse jérémy clapin guillaume laurant
pur j'ai perdu mon corps alors romain de
polanski nommé deux fois aux césars est
ce que ça vous choque pas oui vraiment
mais ça me choque oui alors vous savez
comment ça se passe les ehdaa c'est un
collège de cinq mille personnes
les professionnels exactement qui donc
sélectionne des films donc pour vous
romane polanski n'aurait pas dû être
nommé aux césar alors plusieurs choses
parce que je pense que là aussi il faut
peut-être qu'on arrive à sortir des
caricatures et c'est qu'on peut le faire
dans cette émission d'abord l'académie
des césar elle a fait beaucoup d'efforts
sur la question de l'égalité femmes
hommes il ya deux ans elle a célébré
mitu et la parole des femmes dans le
monde du cinéma et la parité dans un
certain nombre d'équipements maintenant
dans les césars sous l'impulsion d'alain
persan et ça je pense que c'est positif
ça doit être salué mais il ya un message
très paradoxale qui envoyait parce qu'on
voit que la sont sélectionnés à la fois
le film de céline sciamma portrait de la
jeune fille en feu qui célèbre la
liberté des femmes dans son message
adèle haenel qui a parlé d'abus sexuels
subis dans son enfance elle est aussi
nommé aux césars et fille à côté de ça
on a remué de polanski est effectivement
moi je m'interroge sur le message qui
est envoyé aux victimes de violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui découvre sa
statistiquement il y en a forcément
autour de cette table et dans le public
et moi je pense à chaque fois encore une
fois aux personnes à ce qu'elles
ressentent à l'émotion que ça doit
susciter chez certaines d'entre elles
vous savez on a beaucoup dit dans les
débats sur me to win et quand une femme
part d'un viol sa ruine la carrière du
pauvre homme accusé etc etc
manifestement non et moi je crois que là
la ferme mis tout ça démarre avec la
pierre harvey weinstein par le cinéma
par le cinéma on a pu faire un grand pas
en avant
et chacun s'est interrogé sur la culture
du viol dans son secteur
il faudrait pas que par le cinéma en
face trois pas en arrière avec laisse
alors j'ai tout simplement un règlement
est ce que vous répondez marlène
schiappa aux personnes qui disent
pourquoi pénaliser des personnes qui ont
travaillé sur le film puisque jean
dujardin par exemple est nommé comme
meilleur acteur
bon alors roman polanski est nommé comme
ayant réalisé
je crois qu'il a aussi d'autres choses
comme les décors les costumes pourquoi
pénaliser ces personnes surtout que
c'est un sujet très important
c'est ainsi son film j'accuse et c'est
vrai que pas la mine de rien la cause
dans le film est importante
vous vous auriez pénaliser tout le monde
ou est ce que vous dites on peut
dissocier donc toutes ces équipes ont
travaillé dessus le réalisateur romane
pas l'once polanski de l'homme romane
polanski alors d'abord moi j'veux pas
favorable à la censure c'est important
de le dire j'ai jamais appelé au boycott
de ce film je le dis parce que d'autres
choses ont été dites s'appelle pas la
censure je n'appelle pas au boycott
chacun est libre d'aller voir
manifestement il ya beaucoup de monde
qui est allé faire la démarche d'aller
voir ce film
maintenant moi je n'irai pas chacun est
libre de ses choix moi je ne ferai pas
la démarche
vu la position qui est la mienne du nez
combats qui sont les miens depuis très
longtemps
ça va pas faire la démarche d'aller
acheter un ticket de cinéma pour un film
qui est réalisé et scénarisé par un
homme multiplement accusé de viol parce
que je suis du côté des victimes et du
côté des femmes et 11 il faut dissocier
l'homme de l'oeuvre fort bien
dix autres sholom de l'oeuvre mais là
c'est l'homme qui a proposé la
récompense comme meilleur réalisateur
et si nous les étapes les monts sur
scène et que la salle se lève et
l'applaudît tu vois moi je me demande ce
que ressent une victime de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle pas forcément
monsieur polanski une femme qui a vécu
ça où un homme demeurant et qui voient
ça c'est quoi le message qu'on lui a dit
qu'on aurait peut-être dû juste le
retirer du meilleur réalisateur à la
limite non je m'interroge sur le choix
qui a été fait maintenant il ya encore
des votes la ceinture de nominations y
en a 12 ha non d'evra qui sera nominé on
entendra sombre arrigoni des césar voilà
il y verrons quelle sera la froisser
fréquents comme je les dis je doute
maintenant il en est un et je pense mine
de rien que ça va ça va jouer dans
l'otan ce que je pense que les gens vont
pas voter pour roman polanski ils vont
se dire voilà je vais pas non plus le
lui donner un césar donc voilà ce qu'il
faut pas nier ce sentiment de vengeance
aussi qu'il reviendra bien le bac n'a
pas vraiment moi je trouve ça totalement
incohérent parce que vous dites d'à côté
il ya des films qui font la promotion de
la cause féminine ou demi tout ce qu'on
veut et puis de l'autre de et roman
polanski
le film de roman polanski si c'était une
apologie du viol qu'il faisait ou des
thèmes anti féministe mais c'est pas ça
donc vous
sur l'homme et pas du tout sur le fait
ça ce qu'il défend j'accuse
c'est plus c'est plutôt ensuite assure
que ses notes j'observe que romane
polanski aurait donc tous les droits en
france de circuler tout à fait librement
de faire ce qu'il veut sauf de recevoir
un césar
moi je pense grand mal de polanski mais
que simplement les savoirs choix mais
soit c'est injuste c'est son avis
personnel laquelle des noms mais soit il
est coupable et à ce moment là
sa place est en prison s'il est pas en
prison ils arrêtent tous les droits je
comprends pas c'est que ce truc est ce
que vous existez respirer vivre
travailler et être vénéré c'est là la
différence vénéré c'est la lettre il l'a
dit pour l'instant c'est une différence
voix qui la france fait partie des rares
pays où roman polanski ne risque pas
d'être extradé ne risque pas d'être
inquiétées moi je le regrette parce que
je prendrai beaucoup de mal de polanski
tout simplement je suis légaliste s'il a
tous les droits de citoyens il a aussi
tous les droits de réalisateur est ce
que vous faites c'est quand même un
appel à une censure 1 à 10 seulement pas
alors on ne devrait pas moins de 20 ans
devrait réfléchir
mettez le en prison si les psychiatres
alors d'abord je ne suis pas juge moi
comme toutes ses couleurs mais je
réponds ce que c'est très important je
suis très attaché à la justice et je
crois qu'en matière de violences
sexuelles
nous avons un grand besoin de justice
qui s'exprime dans cette affaire juste
il est aussi dans les différents livres
qui ont été publiés je pense olive le
consentement de vanessa spring aura je
pense au livre de sarah abitbol un si
long silence et je pense qu'on observe
qu'il ya là un désir de justice et je
les entends je m'exprime là au nom du
gamer déclenché le poids pendant les
gersois alors c'est ce que je suis en
train de vous dire s'il veut aller au
bout de mon raisonnement
nous notre rôle qu'est ce que c'est en
tant de pouvoirs publics c'est de
permettre à chacune et à chacun de
saisir plus facilement la justice parce
que pour toi mais bien sûr que si ça
parle de chat tout à voir avec le
dossier polanski parce que vous déplorez
qu'il n'y ait pas de justice il ya des
femmes comme valentine monnier qui parle
des dizaines d'années après une fois
qu'il ya presque soit donc nous notre
devoir de responsables politiques c'est
de permettre à chacune et à chacun de
saisir la justice pour les chaînes pour
cela je le
nous avons lancé une plate-forme si ça
vous intéresse pas les questions des
victimes de violences sexistes vous dis
tranquillement
donc je m'adresse à son sujet un tout
petit peu grave si vous permettez donc
je m'adresse aux personnes n'est pas au
sujet va chercher je sais ce que je suis
en train de dire si j'en mets classique
vous pouviez finir nous avons lancé une
plate-forme qui est disponible 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 avec des policiers
et de gendarmes formés pour traiter les
questions violence sexiste autre
optionnelle ça va nuire je pars et on
les violences poing gauche - fr c'est
bien et les gens qui ont été victimes de
violences sexistes et sexuelles dans
leur enfance ou à l'âge adulte peuvent
la saisir l'ambiance et je sais que je
vais tout repassé massa concert vers le
chemin de la justice et que justice
comprend plus les choses très wallemme
châtenay malabry cote
elle donne son avis elle peut donner son
avis comme tout le monde le dow jones by
alors ministre
l'endroit est ce que je vais vous en
laisse années lorsque j'ai un ministre a
plus droit de donner son avis à la
limite de l'égalité hommes-femmes
elle donne pas son avis sur romane
polanski nommé aux césar elle n'a pas
donné son avis sur surprenant mais c'est
vrai sur ce n'est pas prête
mais polanski il a un mandat
international contre lui il a reconnu
des faits de pédophilie meena lee t il a
reconnu aujourd'hui la cérémonie des
césar sans se comporter comme un jury un
tribunal ou un procureur peut décréter
que par éthique elle ne veut pas
dissocier l'homme pédocriminels qui a
reconnu ce crime et qui veut échapper la
justice à ne se rendant pas devant la
justice qui lui a assigné mandat
international tout en effectivement
étant un artiste qu'on expose le maire
toi mais non on va parler notre règle
notre règle ne permet pas l'extradition
valoir à ce qu'il ne fallait pas
l'extradition qu'il faut répondre
que vouloir que les césar et une éthique
l'éthique on dirait que c'est un gros
mot que c'est un mot qui doit pas
exister
mme encore une fois sans être jugés on
peut dire au nom de monétique polanski
je ne veux pas dit c'est aussi l'homme
de l'artiste ses thèmes pédocriminels
qui a reconnu son crime
donc il ne peut pas être honorée dans
notre pays parce que ça voudrait dire
que le boucher du coin lui si les
pédocriminels il va avoir un gros contre
lui mais polanski c'est intelligentia
parisiano culturelle elle s'auto
protègent à leurs récompenses
alors qu'il a violé une petite c'est un
truc de fou quand même alors s'y opèrent
en tout cas marlène schiappa a réagi là
dessus d'un roman polanski est bien
nommée aux césars et comme vous l'avez
dit a priori ils ont dit donc l'oeuvre
de romane polanski de l'homme
romane pensif